I'm glad you bring up the idea of
the work factor and the resources.
I guess we hear people saying
adversity is going to prevail, or
we need to be paranoid or
hyper-paranoid.
How do we strike a balance
between how paranoid we are and
the price we pay for it?
>> Well, one I think,
typically we aren't paranoid enough.
Actually, I would say first we need
to we design things we need to assume
there's an adversary.
Which a lot of people don't do.
Particularly when products
are rushed to market.
And then I don't think that we
assume an adversary is as powerful.
We assume the adversary is stupid.
Which is, again, a bad, bad idea.
And then, I think we can even really
be a little more paranoid than that and
assume they can do a little
bit more than we think.
Maybe a lot more, depending on how
important the information the system
you're trying to protect actually is.
When it comes to trade off, though,
you could put an infinite amount of
resources making something secure.
And conventional wisdom says, and
actually I would say best practice from
industry, is to form a calculation.
So the amount of money you're
putting into securing a system
shouldn't exceed the value of
the item you're actually protecting.
If you're building a vault to hold
a $10 item, something's wrong.
So that's part of the calculus.
The other calculus,
I think, is I personally I don't want to
live in a world with perfect security.
The amount of pain involved
in our day to day lives
makes an overwhelming amount of security
very, very unpleasant place to be.
So it really comes down to risk.
Life is about risk.
Banking is about risk.
Crossing the street Is about risk.
So each organization has to determine
how much risk they're willing to take.
Understand its security cost
in terms of time and money and
resources and
frustration of your actual user base.
There have been times that I haven't
been able to get into the building
where I work because of some
glitch in the security system or
I forgot my ID card or
my pass card in another place.
So it comes at a cost.